el gobierno peruano aprobó declarar el
estado de emergencia por 45 días en lima
y el callao ante el incremento de
asaltos y asesinatos la norma que regirá
a partir de este viernes se establece
que las fuerzas armadas apoyarán a la
policía en el control de la seguridad
fuentes del ministerio del interior- nos
indican que se suspenderán los derechos
a la inviolabilidad de domicilio
libertad de tránsito en todo el país
libertad de reunión y seguridad personal
las autoridades peruanas buscan
controlar la ola de delincuencia que
según diversos colectivos civiles se les
ha escapado de las manos con la norma
tratan de recuperar la confianza de la
población y disminuir los altos índices
delictivos en la capital peruana pero
algunos expertos advierten que el estado
de emergencia no tendría buenos
resultados si es que el gobierno de
pedro castillo no trabaja de manera
multisectorial un plan de operaciones
conjunto entre la sociedad civil fuerzas
armadas y la policía